greetings welcome to podcast Ville the
Church of what's happened now is brought
to you by my favorite me undies every
year millions of people received the
least like gift of all time
underwear plain white underwear but we
still give it to our family and our
loved ones who just don't want it forget
that this year will go and deep me
undies made underwear the perfect gift
that everyone is get going to love you
for
it's a goddamn holiday miracle this year
don't give underwear give me a lease
listen to what I'm gonna do for you this
holiday season I'm gonna get you 20% off
the softest underwear and socks you'll
ever wear free shipping and hundred
percent really 100% ready 100%
satisfaction guaranteed go to me on
these comm slash Joey right now that's
me undies com slide Joey right now
supplements listen you could go knock
yourself out I'm a fat [ __ ] I got
problems let me tell you will heal me on
it from the alpha brain you think I
smoked all this reefer you know
balancing the acupuncture and on it the
alpha brain number two the protein drink
I drink in the morning I either do the
acai vanilla or the cacao m4s protein
with the hemp protein tremendous or
shroom tech support and immune you see
these Japanese people walking in the
airport with a [ __ ] mask on [ __ ] no
me I don't need the [ __ ] mask cuz I
take shroom tech immune I sit there like
a doctor I breathe air I inhale farts I
fought back that's cuz I got shroom tech
immune you want some supplements go to
island comrade now impress in church CH
you are CH and get 10% off your first
order delivered tea house every week
people bother me Joey where do you get
your keys from they hit me up here you
have it
fuji sport calm fuji sport calm they got
an a5 and an eight-six for the buddha
types like me i even went down to 185
since i joined you Jitsu how do i know
cuz
sent me a free elemental gate either go
for the elemental the super Otto or the
psycho
I like the super Otto whatever the [ __ ]
it's called like a [ __ ] all
right do me a favor go to Fuji
sports.com right now press in Church CH
you are CH and get 10% off your first
order
put on some woolly cologne for these
[ __ ] are you [ __ ] not so
what that's off the album I don't even
know 1971 who I'm paying crime pays
there you go [ __ ] uncle Joey
here with my favorite [ __ ] Puerto
Rican Cuban and my favorite Christ
killer Happy Hanukkah three weeks
thank you anyway so we got a show with a
special story feed because people always
make fun and all and Benjamin and Sarah
Tiana and Pauly Shore we're taking an
intimate story about what happened last
time my girl hater visited us over on
the Lankershim at the death office
between the [ __ ] a weed store and
Jeffrey Dahmer's cousin he was cutting
bodies in there you could smell the
[ __ ] livers and a homeless guy and the
homeless guy that robbed the Liddy
anyway so just for my defense I don't
really care yes get high and nothing
makes a little difference to me what
they want to do with their lives I love
him that I got him on this show cuz I
got some type of admiration for so last
time eighty come on and we offered a
bong hit another man but being Lee weed
stars one thing led to another hater sat
there for about an hour and a half and
kept looking at me and leaving her mind
she's like what these guys are having a
great time
[ __ ] if their eyes are red and an
impulse I see her reach grab a star and
she eats the whole [ __ ] thing I had
looked at a win all right well cool and
the podcast is wrong you know I ain't
starting toward ready I was hungry and I
see a change coming over hater and she
gives me a hug Lea hug and she leaves
and take it from there I got I stopped
at the in and out on Lankershim cuz I
couldn't drive anymore
my heart was just like palpitating which
was is like half a block block I was
like I can't do it so I called my kids
and I said you guys gotta come get me
and my son came and got me and they said
I was walking around in circle and I was
just
they said I lost my mind and then I I
started saying I'm gonna die I feel like
I'm gonna die
take me to the hospital I'm gonna die so
when I got to the hospital I had to
panic attack so they had they almost
broke my arm I was telling him giving me
these shots and they they thought I was
like a drug addict my son was like she
never does this I don't know what's
going on and the doctor was like yeah
sure she does like poor kid he's got a
life for his mom it was just it was
hilarious though it was really funny
they keep you there overnight yeah it
was and they let me go in the morning
but it was two days I you told me cuz I
talked to you and you said you're not
gonna feel better until tomorrow and I
was like I'll be all right and then the
next day I was still oh yeah thanks dad
it's like a [ __ ] shock
yeah this night I wake up with listen I
hate doing Xanax and Valium like my
buddy gives me xanax from time to time
and if I'm on the road I like them as
the time change I can't tolerate the
time change name and my body will stick
to the [ __ ] time change so that means
I'm not going to bed till 3:00 when I'm
in Ohio when I do radio at 6:15 lane so
I'll pop a [ __ ] xanax what to and I
drink a [ __ ] milk or something some
chocolate looking I pass out and I don't
like the feeling in the morning though I
wake up I don't take a longer shower
I'll make coffee in my room then drink
more coffee downstairs I can't smoke
weed so I come back and when I do smoke
weed I gotta take another nap but with
the animals I get up in the morning and
once I shower I'm good Lee has a secret
he says the secret is to take a [ __ ] and
once did rubber little Bowie star [ __ ]
comes out of the ass like a bloody cold
I'm not really a secret they just that
my body stopped prized like I stay
my [ __ ] smelled like stars in the
morning I'm gonna do statistics so far
today we read it we got a weird article
a man contacted me running with it did
you read the article because I'm white
man I thought it was another I put
someone else below are some body and
that's it starting January 1st which is
six weeks away or had apples in the
California will be ten milligrams that
means you know we gotta set up a revolt
we gotta set this into appeals or we
gotta create our own [ __ ] black mark
and I'm out on air you're gonna start
protesting what we got no choice really
got an eternity to [ __ ] revolt this
until January we have people with dicted
can march on the forehead generally the
size and milligrams the face is
revolution them looking out you're a
nice sweet Jewish boy yeah you're the
only one that could yes from the board
they're gonna believe me anything I
wanted so starting tomorrow I think they
might have done this band because of
this podcast tomorrow we're gonna do a
we're gonna start [ __ ] bind the goods
and stop them stockpiling huh what's the
most you guys done cuz I remember the
last time I heard you play every town I
did 3,000 I did above what down no you
didn't just say you always do more than
wrong I was doing 500 when I'm a if a
break yeah yeah yeah that's right I was
eating two pieces of banana bread when
you were still [ __ ] there I'm not
saying you know you don't have a better
resume than I do but I'm saying I've
done more stars than you've done oh you
have done yes I had no cuz I eat five
before you even look at the mouth for
hands at a time sometimes I can virus it
I am this does I really don't think I'm
crazy well that's I think we're OK at
least we're honest about it right a room
but I'm happy you went through that I
was very worried about you
so four thousand milligrams and they're
trying to they're trying to minimize it
to ten yeah listen Ben
no one needs forth work it took us five
years of hard work this is not bid some
[ __ ] to walk in the park this is testing
on when I go to acupuncture
like I got a coupon choice to go every
other week so she to me up mmm-hmm like
smoke will come out of me you could
smell the reefer in the rooms
much pot have you been smoking is there
an alternative tennis you know I studied
anymore and then she would I would eat
it more and then she'd say well
something's going on with your dreams
and your gallbladder is heavy tell her
because realistic believable if that
hurts that that and that that uh chakra
that means there's something going on
there so this last Tuesday I went guys
she tuned me up I'd say our hearts she
told me up all right
thought I had to go home usually
acupuncture day I don't do dick I hate
planning spots on acupuncture day hmm
because I know at night if she did a
good job I'm not gonna want to do that
yeah I told you to drink water Ito I'd
ever and what the [ __ ] of acupuncture
sink it and this time I was so tired
when I got home I slept three hours that
after though I used to go there for an
hour there know what done for three not
one of the half but three and I went the
bed last night they had to be 11 o'clock
and I woke up with six straight usually
I got up three times to pee cuz I'm over
50 that last that [ __ ] I slept right to
six like a soldier had a pee like a [ __ ]
it was coming out of my ears but they
should told me she was here recently she
came on about three weeks ago two weeks
healed promote her movie which one
number one yeah yeah short film
perverted [ __ ] section you know say
the name of movie is perfect yeah
so somebody called earlier there but
distribution something yeah told me did
she do edibles she see I forgot what she
told me I talked to her today those
things yeah no no she said she was
talking about the show I [ __ ] call as
the one I do I call Felicia by the level
I plan to see that show bull should be
with some story I'm gonna have to plant
flowers and I have to get recipes ready
I'm doing a piece for some magazine
nervous did you bathe yeah he's you know
he had one way you asking me that
cuz but two o'clock the Moga take a
breather come over and go see the cat's
I don't see it for 20 minutes that's
exactly what she does
mm-hmm so we should come zone will be
hole in the backyard we do a couple
pipettes we [ __ ] about comedy for
eight minutes she tells me oh there's no
woman other comedies don't line up and
yeah then my wife comes back their bells
behind the wall three of us talk for 15
minutes to Felicia leaves hmm so we get
we them saying like the glue still there
I love her to death
yeah me too I love that woman to death I
got a torture I gotta be straight with
her all the time you know she comes to
me and says [ __ ] to me that's outrageous
I don't choke them because I love her
it's against the law that's and I'll
think about it I think about who it's
coming from and I love her even more god
bless him because our heart is
straight-up gold absolutely magical
another grain of gold and she's a real
comic yeah when I look at her I don't
know there's a man or a woman she's
ambiguous to me if she's a real comic
yeah I've already set the mark of what
you know I went on and said Felicia I
did a big favor
now you know how to sweet this girl is
if you think these people are sick in
cabin space in louis c.k Felicia
Michaels could put me at the [ __ ] jam
I with the Felicia Michaels because I
went to Felicia Michaels the first time
I was in the CD cover in Volusia and
even a picture Mina's a confessional in
this church let's go to a church and
take a few pictures
Joey it's against the threats against
not that it's against nothing whether
you're a photographer people gotta
Cambodia they get shot and I'm s you
know [ __ ] going to a church room okay
so I took it for the church sure enough
that's confessional I stood next to the
door she took a picture was to cover my
CD I'm not Felicia any and for the grass
be perfect the next time I have an idea
for something where I got my balls from
you know I couldn't ask her on the phone
that's the type of thing you gotta ask
her a tough face cuz you gotta watch the
cracking music so I went there I was
like nothing like nothing ever happened
and they said please can I talk to you
for a second
if Campbell didn't tell me you know me
I'll just happen again
it was coming back that you for a favor
I went the back of the list I have this
document for him know where I got my
balls from do you mind taking a picture
of my boss it was 9:30 in the water
you ever see a beautiful face well I'll
do it button yet so I had to hold my
dick up in my hand and she photographed
me and then she got into it like I first
she was like hey Frieda way then she got
close and closed until I was posed of
this [ __ ] so I don't know we picked the
picture that we said oh I never imagined
that the nobody that's the covers her
taking those pictures she's a
photographer yeah no but a year ago she
calls me you don't call you what
happened you know us pictures of your
balls or like put them over your book
and my kids found them oh that's a great
picture for your kids the fine she's a
[ __ ] great lady but you gotta try I
gotta talk to her from time to time I
how do I give a little thing as he gets
mad at me for two days now likewise he
gets feisty though hello please she's
always [ __ ] feisty so my dad's always
some mention Germans or some Cheetos
[ __ ] crazy
you know I did my fundraiser when I was
raising outrage I'm sorry is Ralph no I
know you were but she went onstage and
did her set and then she cut her set
short she took a hat with her and she
passed the Hat around and told the
people she was gonna match the money and
she collected like two hundred and fifty
dollars and she made that the charity
seven hundred and fifty dollars which I
thought was awesome it was great because
she was so selfless in that moment and
she killed
she went she's a [ __ ] the local
[ __ ] specialist man yeah so what's
going on in Puerto Rico give me the
report of you let you as her cousins
relatives aunts uncles bad it's bad and
and when people say is getting better or
when they say you know Puerto Rico is we
got this and we got that is bad the
electricity is off February yeah there
is not going to be
April they had a power surge with a
little bit of electricity that was there
out again so like the majority of the
island doesn't have any electricity and
it's gonna take years to rebuild it's
like the cases of water and food all of
that is great it's gonna take years to
people lost their house all my aunts all
my family my family's family they're all
in one house cuz everybody lost their
house so they all live in one house now
and half of them have go to Miami to get
jobs there's a little city outside of
Orlando like a suburb Kissimmee jism
where a lot of Porter we got family
there too it's crazy I did a show there
one time like I'm believe how many
Puerto Ricans what the [ __ ] show the
promoter couldn't believe promoter was
like she's Puerto Rican and she was
doing a dance night so Mesa doin economy
shows she did the math and she highly
angel Salazar and they were busted
through a door they had a whole have
another show and you know it's crazy how
you know well where's the biggest Puerto
Rican community checking out the biggest
Porto Rican community United States not
New York
that's Cleveland your heart oh yeah
there I wasn't yes I was in Ohio a few
months ago those are the card business
matters a lot of Puerto Ricans moved
there and you know they have eight kids
before they die those [ __ ]
don't stop jack yeah we're everywhere
it's so funny of the I was telling uh
well I say to my stand-up now people
know what I am cuz it only took a
category five hurricane for people to
know what a Puerto Rican is cuz people
always ask me here you're really tall
for a Mexican I'm kind of Mexican are
you
you know I say the con with papers but
don't get mad or get mad I don't care
you're still working a lot yeah I've
been working a lot um you know how you
went every time we and Felicia talked
about this like I don't have to see you
all the time when I see you I get this
little injection of energy and the molar
uh the more I don't give a [ __ ] on stage
the more I work and
I always thought it'd be the other way
around but I just had to come to grips
with I'm not I'm not one of those silly
comedians I'm not gonna dance on stage
I'm not gonna rap I got a story to tell
I'm a storyteller and that's my stand-up
and it's been the best thing for me is
it's liberated me it's just telling my
stories and just being free how the [ __ ]
do you think I feel oh you know for 15
years 12 years I was on stage chuckling
John chuckling jive and he [ __ ]
making strides and then one day you find
your voice you find your true voice by
mistake and you do something and you
find it by mistake you don't know what
for me is the belly room I was doing a
one-man show in the belly room and I
start own stories and the stories aren't
like don't stand up when you don't stand
up you're trying to be a machine gun
like when you tell a story it is what it
is so there's lapses and silence yeah
that you have to learn to deal with and
really it's a big difference telling a
story then telling jokes on stage and
that was the first time that I went into
myself and said oh [ __ ] I'm never gonna
do that again you know say like I'm
never gonna show that do it again
that's not way no that's not good but
the more I showed that dude the better
it got yep and we were coming to this
town and go to my first audition as a
limo driver and I asked somebody that I
knew I called him up you so really good
acting there like five movies then he
moved back to Jersey but he did a great
van Damme movie
movies he was in he was great that I
call them up like a woody doing these
auditions he goes you're not gonna
understand this right now I'm telling
you this is the simplest way I could
explain it to just be yourself
yeah I don't like be myself always there
about acting
how can I read myself and be a [ __ ]
actor at the same time and ever since
that night at The Comedy Store belly
room my acting auditions changed you
don't want the two auditions for last
week but I wasn't shocked I didn't yet
hmm because I've been doing this for 20
years now if you give me two days on the
audition see is different does a
different game as popular chance see
there's so popular outdoor lights
yep so now what happens otherwise that
means the auditions gonna be that much
stronger
cuz I'm much more confident when I go in
there I think the line the glass is with
me but I hide them and I take the sides
in and I pray that this good light if
there's good light and it's big I could
see and then get away with it I always
keep the paper up to stay centered why
[ __ ] around why get off and have to go
to the couch and get the paperwork or
them have to give me the script I always
bring the script I don't give a [ __ ] if
it's the fourth time and I know it
back-to-back I always bring it into
Center me you know trying something to
work with I miss but these two auditions
I end them one was from both of them
orphan gangsters hmm I used to get those
just walking in the room I used to get
those walking in the room guys would
look at me and go [ __ ] [ __ ] guy up
tonight dog it's a different game up
there G has anyone had an audition ever
brought up the podcast before how they
ever been like oh because they they're
putting YouTube kids in movies now so I
figured maybe they'd want some of those
of the podcasts for me it's not
that the 16 auditions I used to get no
more they used to be a you know it was
too theatrical auditions that kept you
alive from 2000 to 2004 this is the life
I live
I got jobs work and opening for Rogen
and I acted and acting means this every
week you have two auditions
ultimately they're gonna be on Tuesday
depending on what Liz and I have one
Tuesday and one Thursday the Tuesday
one's gonna be for a TV show because you
read Tuesday you're gonna produce his
Wednesday and you either work Thursday
Friday Monday and Tuesday a winter
you follow me that's how it used to be
and they used to give you three days and
you really work to one day you went down
there and you got some feet and you
stood there while they shot somebody
else
and they sent you home you didn't make
overtime but they paid you Freight that
you were gonna be jiggered offer for
your house anyways that's why it was a
different game now they'll tell you
either one day guest star and you're
like what are you talking about this
eight seats we're gonna shoot those
[ __ ] in one day and you're like
god damn you people are [ __ ] slave
drivers damn it's a Reds it's really
weird how it's changed so you always had
something in the pipe yep okay you
always has something in the pipe so you
went on to theatrical auditions and to
commercial auditions that's 16 and month
if you go on eight commercial auditions
every month for four months you're
booked to come herself because I used to
keep records that's the number eight how
do the eight you're gonna go to produce
is three times you're gonna be on hold
once and book once those are the odds
you don't think like those away and they
were for me theatrical was crazy
I would blank for a whole month but then
get three callbacks to produce the
sessions for films and booked one thing
the following month so on all and then
that audition you went to in January
they just call you back in May okay cuz
the money from Spain fell through and
how they got the money from an American
company and they got [ __ ] val kilmer
to join the cast you know saying like
it's always a [ __ ] story but it's a
different game now now it's there are no
rules there's no rhyme or reason and
like he said the YouTube kids or
whatever it is and um you know whatever
it is it's just a whole different game
and you gotta be you just your mind has
to be right for this now cuz this is so
a whole bunch of [ __ ] going on and you
don't I don't I don't even know anymore
I'm like oh you know you're sitting here
you just won't put different actors at
parks and different kids functions I see
guys hey I ignore me we both read oh man
yeah and I'll ask them what's going on
with you man I know three guys
personally that have already gotten
early retirement Dan they hit 55 and
they said would take my sag money things
are that bad
then we'll take the pension early
pension you lose a couple thousand
dollars but that's how much their lives
have changed and these don't work and
get and get pension or no yeah you can
still work they'll just won't take the
that'll save your money over one month
okay let's add more to your pension fund
uh I'm not retiring [ __ ] I'm gonna be
great grandma listen and look at
something like Judy soprano yeah he was
what how old will he got the soprano you
don't want to know and he worked for
five years they know he resolved they
knew they had to shoot him out quickly
you know he's gonna fall asleep on you
gotta shoot those out quick that means
uh those guys are ready to go at 9:00
they've been up since 4:00 people saying
they've been up since 4:00 so they're
the first shot they're ready to go yep
they know their lines those old guys but
you got until about 10:30 that's their
first night so you better get them good
before 10:30 how long is the first nap
45 minutes I gotta go lay down for a
little waffle so oh shoot around them
don't do [ __ ] like this he'll make a
comeback before lunch they'll give him
some soup
don't put his socks back on his shoes
her go out there again and do another
how how would I have then it's lunchtime
he goes back to his trail and gone
they shoot something else then they
shoot him and he's done for the day
now what did I like one 2:30 3 o'clock
he's back on the hill town this not only
traffic any of the Van Buren expressway
about 3 o'clock every day
whatever the [ __ ] he lives Jesse's all
those people you want to get them kids
you have kids on the set or baton on the
set you have a kid on this set they have
to take a certain amount of breaks and
they have to go to school or they
shouldn't so if there's a hate they
can't exceed more than a doubt with day
so it's four hours a class and four
hours of shooting or six hours of class
and two hours of shooting don't quote me
but there are guys that sit there
teachers with a [ __ ] clock you know
when you should have moved with a dog
Lord Jesus Christ God they're better
than you do
yeah they only know if the dog would
only knew he come back to life and go
gibbehhh' I want my full [ __ ] check
[ __ ] I got me living in a [ __ ]
house next to some other [ __ ] dogs
Jenny next to me with the paper I'm
making yeah they do they treat the
animals really well like first off you
[ __ ] to make a movie one of them you
gotta have an ass a game animal that I
got animal control
yep everything is on the clock Lee you
got that dog for 30 minutes go you can't
eat this can he jump off that cliff
let's measure it happen measure the
cliff look at this another double yeah
can you shoot the dog no we brought this
dummy in and we're looking from this
angle bleeding well we don't want to if
we don't want the dog to be scared if he
sees the blood I don't [ __ ] say [ __ ]
to you that your wiggle fall off but it
doesn't matter that's that's part of it
and where is Air Bud now yeah where does
that bud and where's this or was that
it's really [ __ ] amazing to see when
you work with an animal and you know
listen the moat the six movies I worked
on with an animal it was a low-rent
movies so the dog was half [ __ ] just
that wasn't [ __ ] no [ __ ] top of his
class you know saying the dog who saved
all those movies that dog he wasn't the
sharpest dog in the shed he had eight
smaller brothers they gave him away last
and they really worked on them they gave
him special that
no [ __ ] thing but that dog didn't
look dick about dick dick about there
you couldn't [ __ ] believe how bad he
was we used three I'm on one movie the
one dog in three movies and the other
dog and three other movies he looked the
same nice dog
and came up here they said hello it's
but a little about action then about cut
they don't know think about that so you
know time is money so come on - tick
tock
you gotta get those dogs like on a black
[ __ ] market what's the weirdest
animal you guys I've ever worked with a
man alligator
oh I'm glad I got alligators no no they
offered me they black me out you gotta
go to a tub Oh
alligators a little underwear on this
[ __ ] [ __ ] you this fear factor you know
this had to be eight nine ten years ago
for I forget what it was something with
an alligator something that was tougher
than alligator your underwear or
something like that I don't [ __ ] know
I read this thing about how alligators
how small their brains aren't like they
have probably the smallest brains of
animals but they not a bite yeah that's
what I'm saying they're like when people
say oh he's trained I'm like you he's
been trained you can't untrain a
alligator I believe that at some point
they're all they are all gonna kick back
into their nature you know what I mean
like I have a friend used to play for
the Minnesota Vikings and his girlfriend
brought home a mountain lion a baby
mountain language she thought it was a
regular kid in it and then she invited
me over there and she was like don't
worry he's been declawed and defamed and
I was like did that [ __ ] get
deep mountain lions like I don't
understand why people think that these
animals was it a full mountain lion like
yeah wasn't my she captain she kept it
did she write it around her house or
something no she just thought that it
was it was an exotic animal and they
were rich and it was does it depend get
that licenses to have those is against
the law yeah
eventually better but she wanted to keep
it does she want to keep it I told this
guy I cop drugs on time involved in a
couple of times in module and snakes
everywhere yeah so when you walk through
this house from time to time you go
listen be careful huh one of my [ __ ]
killer Panthers got away ah he'll wrap
himself around your leg when I got the I
have to bet them real close to me to
shoot baby life in 15 minutes oh my god
know all that [ __ ] there's a level yeah
there's a level with uncle Joey all
right I like animals from the distance
when they can't get to me and I can't
get to them I don't want to shoot a lion
I don't want to shoot a digital look
even if I miss a piece of beautiful ham
will you look at your tail [ __ ]
amazing
when you see a lion he's lame they got
flies all over and you don't give a [ __ ]
oh my god yeah and he's beautiful
they're there at but so I lived in Miami
I lived in a neighborhood whether it was
all buildings and there was one house
and it was a drug dealers house they got
busted
they had a tiger in the house they had a
monkey they had all kinds of snakes the
reason they got busted is cuz the monkey
got out every bunch of feed him to the
tiger no they know they just had all
these exotic animal that I'm not in
Barrow and he had all these animals in
the house the monkey got out all these
cops around our neighborhood that's how
eventually they got buses drug dealers
lose them I never lose control too much
money especially when they're living in
a neighborhood full of miserable broke
people I lost control but I never lost
the outside like I've always always
always always bullied the little low
profile you never want to doubt like as
long as you can huh
you never want to have like an exotic
pet no no I'm talking about these with
drug dealers nobody animals not first of
all they did was a neighborhood with no
you know it was the hood if you know
anything about this neighborhood so it's
tough enough to have a pit bull yeah no
no no no no they got a lion a [ __ ]
monkey what else how all kinds of
exotic snakes yeah you know it's like
the it's like us moving it by paying go
knock down that office this office in
that office and get some animals in this
[ __ ] giving wine this [ __ ] so
when people come over to do a podcast
they don't feel uncomfortable love with
the edibles that is edibles the Lions
they're in there have like glass and
Adam wall so they can see the way just
people go [ __ ] nuts my point is what
like I went nuts but I didn't go
ridiculous I was pale you could tell I
had this slept in a week right and you
know but the the fanciness like I never
that's rule number one where I grew up
like you would listen we don't give a
[ __ ] yeah you take that money you hide
it and if they come to you and be here
to death and they can't find it and they
don't see that you bought nothing they
got nothing on you if you can justify
your existence they got blood on you and
then always made sense of it if you
[ __ ] you know when we robbed the gold
chains that time you became [ __ ]
Puerto Ricans on the fifth I might not
live here but we went to like fancy
restaurants are you sure the scene this
at 18 getting one you some bowel one
exactly the maitre d gonna call the
[ __ ] these guys man and that's taking
out wads of money that went on for about
a month but I'm talking about after that
I looked and said what the [ __ ] was I
thinking I'm never doing that again
yeah and even an aspirin 83 a little
volt
I had my apartment and I was burglarized
in the apartments but I had an apartment
I had done construction it me and this
old guy that I recollect for eight weeks
and to get the power we had the keys to
all the apartments they was he killing
those four people people like you that
are millionaires and buy a house and
Snowmass and go there once a month once
a year
if you're lucky they go there once a
yearly once a year so I would go into
their houses and get a closet out so
everybody has a closet outside their
door to hide this key is mm-hmm I would
get the key that don't get a double key
it's not hiding my money
whatever coke I stole and whatever
[ __ ] anything else had money and
hashed I had a bunch of cash and then
[ __ ] [ __ ] box in the back of house
keys but dog I never touched it I lived
under $10 I was making his nutrition and
people looking at me but they foot you
would have seen the other bar you
wouldn't see me on a Corvette you were
the same in a convertible I wouldn't do
that he's fast that money and when
you're ready to split nobody knows
nothing and you got the rest of your
life made and why everybody else is
flashing their [ __ ] just to find hearing
their existence yep nobody knows nothing
I learned that from the legend Meyer
Lansky till the end nobody no none
I didn't make a livin when I got a
pension for 2001 really you're a piece
of the action on kosher chickens out of
[ __ ] still you get 2,000 eggs as my
account there's a code there's a coup
and then people always say well drug
dealers always get busted they get
busted cuz they lose their minds because
they can't do the math yeah and math is
lethal now the [ __ ] math that's the
first thing that stands out there's a
movie called Empire yes have you ever
seen an empire with John Leguizamo and
the guy from Naughty by Nature and
see if it's on their empire there's a
kid on that he's half Puerto Rican half
Italian
he lives on Hollywood Boulevard next to
the juice tent we used to do the juice
damn let's understand the [ __ ] Jew
stand oh you took all juice juice with
the [ __ ] chicken salad say another
what is the honey wheat bread it's a
delicious it's as healthy as [ __ ] there
you don't talk about yeah Holly the
bullet was there they were around the
core I moved he had 97 that one [ __ ]
vine in a parking lot that was going
grass on it and it would be packed every
day and you would see the headshots of
all these actors that will go there but
then they got evicted
now they got gorgeous hotels there they
trade they [ __ ] sold for them they
made big money that chick is smart she's
one of my loved ones third world
countries where there's a dictator cuz
the dictator in all those countries down
there shooting people I love coming here
because I'm in this it reminds me of
being at home like my go-to head pile
that's it right there I have my official
trailer go there this is [ __ ] right
there it's uh it's a C movie at best
that is good
it had his moments what were we talking
about oh yeah yeah these guys sold coke
in Spanish Harlem which everybody did
but there's a scene where he parks a
$70,000 car in the [ __ ] neighborhood
God playing Li what's going on here one
thing that's stuck no no it's really
weird I'm never going is what life is
all about getting it losing it from
needing it living it and dive for it
it's what the American Dream is about
me a $40,000 truck I parked one of the
poorest neighborhoods in the country but
no one touches it why respect my name is
Victor Rosa from Young latinum
good-looking on the streets of New York
they showered the white jacket recent
rain juice fair build an empire but
uptown is another world defined by power
and privilege so what do you do I'm an
investment banker what do you do
obviously whatever it is that I do I'm
not doing enough ah that's for damn sure
he could be a part of this too if you're
gonna do this go in knowing that he's
not smarter than you
I got this investment opportunity and I
can make the most money - can I have it
now get out or what see this here man
all this right is Pam what's that
I need to diversify just white guy the
hottest cattle more female this is a
would someone be easy you do your part
o'clock this movie will be on the guy
Rob's his D this is Jack Whelan he takes
the Columbia this reinvesting sent the
guys double crosses you saying Jack did
this thing
I know he's a bad joke Big Joe will he
was fine but you're only kissed you
think you're too smart
why don't you go back here
I gotta call a woman no shadow ball was
don't have to be a war performances but
if you ain't got sticks to do ever you
like the restrictions now they shoot if
you go back go back a little bit I'm
gonna tell you guys a true [ __ ] story
all right I'm gonna tell you guys I'm
gonna drop some knowledge on you right
here right they go right there a little
bit when their phone at bodega slow and
I right there he's right there put it
right there and I'll tell you when to
stop it he go right there you see that
scene right there that's in front of a
bodega in Miami it's about three blocks
away from Paradise Point Paradise Point
this hotel where you gonna it's not
fancy you stay off for in South Beach
right where South Beach starts and each
room is different they have like the
moon in the Latin room that can hit the
door room if you want the school room
it's got bunk beds so you and your
girlfriend have bunk beds like two
[ __ ] Momo's when you're there this is
the bodega you go to to get now I wish
you could see the front of this see
they're not gonna show tea in the end of
the trailer when you see the fright that
when you see them right there when you
see the front of that it's a micro scene
don't worry about it
that place right there if I'm stuck and
I can get the poreless agua I go in
there and I see what they got on the
lunch menu if they got something simple
like pica D it would write rice or pork
chops with white rice and black beans I
buy the food by the pound
oh yeah and it's [ __ ] tremendous you
know many times I've been at that bodega
as soon as I saw this scene I knew
exactly where they was and when I went
back to Paradise Point I walked over
there and they have pictures like as I'm
on the
even have asked I didn't even have to
ask I know what those that want us
that's my restaurant I've been going
there as all of the kids that's a badass
restaurant and it's not expensive no
that's the beauty of the [ __ ] patois
I've had people go down and go Joey I
went to Gloria Stefan's restaurant
L'Oreal $160 it was luck you should have
called yeah you shouldn't call I know
dumps that you look like that you get to
pick a deal with for fried bananas in a
[ __ ] coconut water and you'll sit
there and go Jesus Christ
I just spent $4 for lunch and it's
delicious I'm moving in the back with no
green card they smuggle during on the
ship via machine gun to work there for
the rest of her life because she was one
of the best chefs in Cuba
that's the type of [ __ ] you got back
there okay it's really weird to [ __ ]
understand but it's a different world
and it happens here in California yeah
some guy owned the restaurant and makes
a lot of best restaurant he's known for
his car near Salawat Enid believe him in
Mexico to rot the debt and get shot by a
chapo [ __ ] no you know put him on a
truck underneath the truck as a carrot
dress him up as a carrot put him
underneath the truck for Halloween and
his smuggle mend and [ __ ] open up a
little bodega stand and let people know
what time it really is carrot Wilson
yes foot care thousand loads go through
that a week you can grandpa you this
chef you wrap them up as a carrot and
you put them this shipment of ten kilos
of coke if you know the jail go to jail
why [ __ ] around with some dude the
dresses are carrot there's a five-foot
carrot now that's a big shipment of coke
well kiddo what happened somebody paid
me fine when I take the call with a
boarder when you meet him at 7-eleven in
New Jersey I don't [ __ ] know Leeds
just tell them buddy take this town
thing okay I love you help me Obi
asterid what's up I said I love that
John Leguizamo has a leather jacket on
in Miami oh yeah yeah definitely PM
nothing
you've got to be melting even this times
you go to Miami dog you get off that
[ __ ] plane and the humidity just sign
in the morgues the do in the morning oh
yeah that's the only thing I like about
Miami and waking up early going outside
and listening to a sprinkler yep
hollow and smelling the water hitting
the grass and just sitting up there with
your cup of coffee and breathing that it
that [ __ ] air tremendous beautiful
and there's nothing like a warm summer
night in Miami that's always it comes on
fire fire you know like those little
small lizards Johnny well with the Tampa
it took me about three hours to see I
was all right and the dump now when I
was a child they [ __ ] scared oh gods
Oh his cousin's you know what I used to
hang him on my earlobes oh I was little
yeah they used to bite and I used to
hang him on me and my brother oh yeah I
used to put him in the coca-cola bottles
with the bugs and watch him eat mint
I was a I was a savage though my dad
used to be oh I stopped by it
I am throw cuz I would be outside like I
wasn't scared of anything
it was it was different time I tell you
to spare my daughter jumbling for the
pool burn crazy sounds right yeah the
point of the other life you know I have
that problem she's not scared
never that's great every once in a while
some if she's tired something she acts
weird
I took it first movie last night disco
called man my agent quality goes hey man
I got the readers call him believe this
I got a call from Disney Pixar they
won't know because your name is Coco if
you're interested and going to a movie
with your family of course they'll pick
you up you have to go play a game and
then watch the movie do it interview and
then there's a party afterward do you
think you want to go there Lego is in
Hollywood they know it's down
the baby gets classic so good that my
wife were just happening we were walking
by the email came up late what do you
think that she would yeah I think she
liked it she's ready I took it for
movies pre-fund she lasted 20 minutes I
need some over we gotta go
no no wait there's daddy so I don't want
that to happen there's a music now if
she put the 3d glasses only a soldier
and what's the whole thing like she
owned the joint and the movie was
[ __ ] for men listen those Pixar
movies oh now he's way better than what
people are doing anymore wait please in
a cult I'm working on them
well they spend time and money but they
get it back 10 times
oh yeah he's actually alone like if they
already broke a record in Mexico they're
already gonna add to the cash registers
in the United States like [ __ ] Sunday
I can't wait to see it though I heard is
really good whoo I cried I laughed I
cried from watching her and I cried on
the plot of the story because it was
just brilliantly done you know yeah I
can't wait to see you but it would look
to the party upstairs and they gave away
dolls and stuff even pictures I took
picture and from the thing I took
pictures of me in her mine why everybody
had a good time how nice and you called
the number and a car came and got you
and they took us home in 20 minutes
that was it I hope my military
everybody's happy whether there's a
[ __ ] family man I should have let more
people know that Cole Cole was my
stripper name cuz I would I really like
to have God yeah I need to get a
nickname that's fifty four years old and
I've had that name since I was three and
he gave it to me maybe ten weeks before
my father uncle it go go because I was
really white and they would scratch them
no little [ __ ] if one kid I'm
bringing you your thing ain't ya why is
he like [ __ ] coconut and my mom no
friends Coco caught him once I got old
but I sort of realized way macoco my
name is Jose but the ones over to
American school that Jose [ __ ] had to go
yeah once I went to PS 166 for all those
New York City kids yeah that Jose had a
go Jack
there was only one other perspective kid
in the class that was Debbie Dominguez
and she was banging in kindergarten bang
did this family not [ __ ] banging like
she was beautiful by the first grade she
showed me at it one time in a 45 you
know singles the little ones and she's
putting on her Teddy's show me at the
before corner under the [ __ ] monkey
bars tremendous and she had five
brothers that were gorillas but I didn't
give a [ __ ] for a quarter I think I'm
gonna get said it was no big deal so
that when Jose became Joey or did he
just go by Coco no I went to my middle
name my middle name is Antonia okay Oh
son told you choice cut out the Jose and
I went to Tommy I was [ __ ] thing at
the moment Tony so for years I was just
Tony and I even had a ring gold ring my
mother got me that said told me see you
aliases now what are you talking about
you so you wondered jelly come into this
show he came back in 1985 oh my god
and Coco is a family name so that was so
totally lasted maybe through the third
grade this stuff where's that part of
Tony what are you talking about yessir
only called me Tony Tony Tony my mother
called me horse Antonio if she was mad
if things were good she called me Coco
and I would be embarrassed for her to
call me Coco so she called me Coco's and
fun of people I wouldn't react to her
put make believe I didn't overseers own
I didn't want to be named Coco but when
I went to Jersey my friends heard
that they just started call me Coco
there was no getting around and I got
pissed off but it was better than them
saying
Jose Antonio Diaz and yeah Nicola guitar
player I was gonna burst to a [ __ ]
door it was about survival and it was
crazy I mean the people who knew me
people kids I knew we take a class
together in high school
Julie yeah awesome a girl Jose Antonio
Diaz and I raise my hand
they were look at me go I thought your
name was coconut no that's my nickname
that's [ __ ] Coco it's Jose Diaz
please know so I can say Jose Diaz
there's no matter you put that in the
NCIC the computer blows up it says check
back with us the month and a half me
yeah because my name was Antonio I get
it but this is like the I feel like this
you know this is a big moment it is a
big moment you just found out about Tony
oh so he's Tony I don't know Tony
someone how would the Catholic school
Tony was Tony for a while but again my
mother ratted me out it when I made my
kamila in the fourth grade so went back
to Coco but time I got out of the fifth
grade it was strain of Coco by the time
I went to McKinley it was still Tony oh
but she called me Coco Coco overtook the
Tony and I just throw away the [ __ ]
ring it just was never gonna work but by
that time my English was good yeah do
you understand I'm trying to say to you
guys so my English is good I didn't want
to show up first day of school New York
City sound only Ricky Ricardo [ __ ] my
name is Jose Diaz and probably I did
sound like the but I watch so much TV
and I said everything big van Dyke said
ten times if Dick Van Dyke said honey
where's the towels honey where's the
towels honey was
how funny was the Taos honey was the
town you know I would just work on the
English accent the American accent New
York accent because my mom always said
you don't want to let people think that
you just [ __ ] spaz love know your
Rissa Delia Betsy doubt you know that
you're for sure though
that's why I always thought that she
always thought I was important that I
spoke English outside the house and
Spanish inside the house yeah that's how
we go to keep both languages alive which
I believe you know and I got a daughter
now that she understands Manish Sharma
[ __ ] say it I gotta hold the knife to
her throat she's too young but yeah my
dad is Cuban Souza there was no English
in the house you would say something in
English even like it get Louie yeah all
right if you say something English came
along at fine young and it feels like
why would Charlie worked my mom in
English and she can understand what you
say yep talk to me in Spanish I go
that's no real happiness you know yes it
would
two days knowing you need money you come
begging me in Spanish and she was
correct
this job is all the other 2000 bill oh
you say then I finally had to break down
and speak Spanish but that's one thing
I've a I respect a lot about Cubans a
very very adamant about the kids
learning how to speak Spanish I'm how to
speak Spanish and just to continue to
speak Spanish because you do learn
English in school we couldn't and my dad
still doesn't speak English the other
day he was talking about transgender
people he called them TransUnion co
yellow trying union guess you know all
cubed man yes doctrine Union and I was
like Bobby it's mean transgender and I I
don't call him papi I call him Orlando
but he is so funny he said thank you
home he called me Eduardo no lost Ron
Union get a condo it's crazy because I
didn't have a Cuban grandfather
I had a Cuban rebels we just didn't talk
but yes I sound Italian yes
from New Jersey let's say some the Cuban
old man mentality still exists in me oh
yeah when I talk to you sometimes UV and
it scares me I have to hide it I have to
keep those views to myself and how well
those type of views and keep to myself
yeah and those are the views I will
discuss because those are views that
cause Wars yeah I'm saying they just
really bad views those old-time Cubans
they specialize in our unit yes they do
and that's why they have those beliefs
yet that was telling me about a can cure
if you feel the Embassy's good buy a
license for arguing and you go to the
parking lot your license files now you
can actually go to the park about your
people files most of the arguments are
about baseball but all those parties all
those you know family parties that's
where those arguments come to so that's
what white they go crazy of feelings
because all those years I want those
reasons that's where it erupts honey
what do you mean erupts right this is
how stupid humans are let's say I was my
sister
we booked that the same mother was
saying Paul I this had been blown people
and I've been raising that kisses he was
[ __ ] for kept my money
Nadia and say her milk a fool you yeah
you know Cuban men will do that me as
being hind his brother who I love that
we love each other with tightest [ __ ]
but guess what dog
guess who watches either son which he
goes to New York to do camrea with me a
new girl of my sound oh yeah yes from
Edina you gave him big ones right Pina
he's 16 yeah all the drinking with you
yeah he's gonna drinking with some bums
on the street oh he's gonna drinking
with his uncle Joey did you smoke power
am never a popular they ever smoke power
in the kids smoke power me ten times you
know
I got his back hook them up I let him
[ __ ] a chick in my house they're right
in their way but you don't need to know
that mom
so now you wanna do what you want to go
to the Bronx and do what comedy and take
him from me big guy this is my son
yeah bingo that's the mentality of a
Cuban men they will argue with this poor
girl about her son and where he stands
but I mean one of her brother
I have no right to say nothing to it and
guess what she knows I'm probably right
yeah absolutely
she'll sit then go this [ __ ] got
my [ __ ] cuz he has yes so although she
is he human matter a different tone I
have to fight that emotion on a daily
basis yes so what were they causing too
much of a disruption on the Cuban
streets or something why do they have
this five-dollar license now because
they want them to go to the park
and if there's a problem they got your
fingerprints and [ __ ] probably yeah to
argue I can argue that are you but
there's mornings when I call you Lee
right and you hang up the phone you
gotta go I'm not sure about Joey
anything right so wait so you're the
milder version of your of your people
I'm already watered down because over
the years oh my god I had a water myself
down because I would not be accepted for
sure
I'm already insecure about Who I am
never mind having that stigma around you
yeah
the things that come out of those meds
he's he's watered down for a Cuban old
man right but he's not he's not watered
down as a person he's full-blown but to
be what a Cuban like some of the things
that my father would say I can never
repeat if I'm married to either right
there right we've been together years we
have a three-year-old and I thought
about the babies in the room but I could
be in the best mood ever yeah
watching TV and I had a walk by me with
that blouse that that's in the old
school that's a kick for a [ __ ] month
either do me a favor go put a sweater on
yep
because that's how they are they're very
good yeah oh you can you let my wife go
now with that shirt yeah you're not
raised you all see that's true I don't
know what my mother raised you but
that's right your mother was divorced
eight times so it's that kind of it's an
it's an honesty that you learn our
language yeah it's like my uh my dad
used to tell us we used to have to take
a bath every night before went to sleep
and when we woke up in the morning by
the tank and then my you know we would
be like well why we got to do that and
he'll be like poke a boil tool through
that again Mary Ellen Oh Chiaki Okello I
think I love [ __ ] sweats in the middle
lane and in my house we have the clean
ass what no dirty ass girls living in my
[ __ ] out anyway why because I said so
that's why
yes oh my god no it's a [ __ ] like I
look at mercy already and I were like
last night she said we want to tell it
to like Coco for the deal was complete
the deal was set a week ago and we pick
a deal with her all week ago and last
night in the car on the way home she
goes oh by the way am I still sleep with
you guys - my wife is looking like wow
holy [ __ ] she remembers some [ __ ]
deal we made a week ago we got home she
loves Chicago pajamas on you know I stay
out there for about an hour or so they
both hoarsely I go and I sleep like a
baby
I love sex I get up smoke some pots of
coffee nicotine gum I feed the cats I
talk to my wife my wife uh she needs to
get up pretty early
please get up some so I don't let me go
back to bed and watch you get up so i
sat there every 10 minutes went by 15 I
heard some movement
I saw pull the blankets down looked on
mother's side look to my side
she looks around the room she like take
a breath like
also she put the blankets over as she
fought though as she went back to bed
okay so I gave it to 8:00 a.m. and I
reach my hand under this sheet that's
not a tick off the side usually she
tickles and giggles she took laying in
and just drew it off that was it slid
off my clothes don't [ __ ] bother me
I'm sleeping god I'm right there I live
like those little nuances tells you you
gotta gotta be able to [ __ ] with her but
she knows I'm next time she knows that
same for boogeyman but she already took
my hand crushed it like last night the
same thing in the middle of night I felt
the kick of me so I tried to push her
like the way she put a light right there
in her psyche she argue with me she was
kicking me and I move a foot so far so I
tickle my foot I grabbed the bottom left
foot and started kicking that little
[ __ ] flat foot down a little sledge
of rock that she has for a foot and
finally she moved it away she moved as
she shook it and I remembered this
morning that's right in the middle that
I had to take off [ __ ] forward for
four [ __ ] hour so she's gonna be fire
already yeah it doesn't take a genius to
see that like I said with the bird
crisis the other hand bird jumped in the
pool
well they heard her jump in the pool I
was washing the football I was involved
I was having a good time with the guys
no but something told me my daughter
would jump in that pool
the phones ain't in yet she loves to
swim it's nighttime
she knows bird she's comfortable there
once the older kids started jumping it I
knew she's gonna jump in I saw her come
over take the fuse off she ran over she
looked she goes no no no I can't that it
took only you look she went over again
look them no no no again no she wouldn't
look she came actually pulled will bring
off a little plastic ring with a gem on
it he did she jumped at her deep end I
go look - boy laughing when I tell you
you don't need to swallow me I already
know what's in those beans yep I already
know you don't need a book
I already see little things and little
things become big things she always has
to wear a dress
Mao is she's know my child so she sits
herself in that room I check on her
every 15 minutes and make sure she's not
blowing up doubts but she's back there
playing with Barbie dolls Hot Wheels
cars dogs you guys were both she has the
hot wheel set up she has the Barbie
dolls just a tent and she's got like a
little thing with two tens I got her and
a couple Barbie doll thank you for the
dolls label he goes for heels
she changed my mom for time okay - yeah
yeah you know so you go back then I'll
sit on my side knock on the door she's
full now if I rely on the door guys
that's right I knock on the door and I
asked her back from it's a boy sure
though you could and then I go class on
your bed and talk to you for a while
I'll sit there and I'll ask again I play
he is healing that really Larry his oh
and I'll sit there like a [ __ ] Bobo I
ask the questions for five minutes
she'll [ __ ] with me but she won't let me
[ __ ] with daddy
can you leave them okay walk out and
then I go in the living room with your
15 minutes my wife goes in there and
pretty much like my whatever come on and
oh she drove me out don't feel too bad
it's a real adventure having a child but
there's people look at their child I
don't know I look at her and I already
know what to expect like I've seen this
show without you did that a couple years
ago I know when I gave my mother
I found the sauce spot my mother's heart
I'll cook it my mom could cook but she
didn't cook should I liked it I was like
yeah like she will cook the deep Huber's
[ __ ] I wasn't ready for the deep Cuba
chef I've seen bumble
yeah all that shit's a delivery love
with chicken delight so I know how to
hold a chicken the way and those days
was like four hours for three pieces of
chicken
we'll cut french fries little thing and
jelly ChaCha with a bun cha cha yeah and
I'm gonna sell the court that he should
treat had talked about this before you
two young fertile a treat as East Coast
goes to delicious
it's like fruit punch but it has a
little kick yeah it's it's a high high
but what happened to [ __ ] high C I
think it's still there has like three
labels when I was a kid that 92 [ __ ]
flavors Jack yeah what was that now is
now it's the second time he did that
would be for Dylan let's take a
dynamiter son Campbell still burning
yeah I think sounds good there mm-hmm we
got boxes of candles a boy sent us a box
of candles there there but the haze like
that I got a substitute candles move
them up but you can visit soon Merry
Christmas [ __ ]
what kind of candle is it some girl came
to visit us last week it says it on the
bottom but I can't smell it what's this
bill that's good smells like that smells
like some fruit I think it's something
vanilla caramel here yeah
no there is caramel in there it's sweet
vanilla cream oh wow don't you gave us
fancy burnt toffee it smells good though
it smells edible smell that's the right
word the way you bend down or change I
want to know you were here your life I
saw you want some crinkle fries just now
crinkle-cut fries are delicious but I
went home last week
I love abuse for myself on Friday night
I did both shows my brother picked me up
and he knows what he wanted l had salad
at 6 o'clock at night I did two shows
that was it how I had a salad like three
or four muscles of marinara announcer at
Rudy's and I said you own pockets dog
from was over to a diner than that base
anything grown up it they redid it
you know first off it's Friday at one
o'clock and there was two tables and
there the place was haunted there wasn't
a soul in there let me hey son thirty
years ago Friday at 1 there was a 1 down
the steps ten-minute wait and you walked
in here a milkshake right off the bat
loving a milkshake dog right off the
battling a beloved chocolate - what he
wanted me to chop you - chocolate some
vanilla strawberry and when you come
back you put your hamburger or your
hamburger the lots or cheeseburger
deluxe which is the [ __ ] cheeseburger
the french fries with them would Sorella
on top and a little gravy do you have to
get the gravy that's the whole patois
really you do is you you get the fork
and you cut into the french fries and
the gravy seeps in into a French fiber
very lightly I don't like a [ __ ]
French fry spoon people saying I'm
philia just very lightly around the fry
to give it that flavor so every time you
take a bite of the thing behind and eat
it by little pickle all together like a
[ __ ] [ __ ] he's making gravy
on the burger you get dipped into the
gravy if you want I want you gravy on
the side but you think about it you have
to put the fries on display listen
you're the Captain Kirk of the
enterprise you do a little [ __ ] you want
I'm just telling you what happened but
this [ __ ] didn't put the gravy
on top of the french fries you put the
gravy over the french fries and you put
some mozzarella on top of it and people
chef I already slipped
so that when you bit in the think squirt
outward because it was like a [ __ ]
french fry gravy pie I don't like it
like that I like the gravy on top
you [ __ ] bake the cheese you burn the
cheese crispy and then you throw the
[ __ ] gravy on top of that I'd love to
get behind the kitchen and teach these
[ __ ] how it's done lace I had
you follow me to help out my diner
I know I can't board am I gonna find
time in between what 2:00 in the morning
for the woman yeah try to get my beauty
sleep look at me now I'm going on seven
[ __ ] hours of sleep I need 15 my age
right now get me them three hours a
night you get inna I've been getting six
at most the time you go to bed
what yeah my phone working it depends
and you wake up at 7:00
yeah wake up six seven if I'm in New
York though I work too late because I'll
do four or five sets a night you sorry
it's okay that's the edibles make you do
that sometimes I am you know babies five
stars but I don't know okay how many
have you eaten
I have we're doing a half could you
punch each that's nothing that's an
appetizer he knows that no it's not
I told them once then I eat to coogee
punch and they looked at me like I was a
crazy person who doesn't go there they
know you're a savage I know now but they
didn't know you need to do hydrate when
you eat edibles I'm trying that's the
most important thing what else has been
going on your wife Rayna movies TV
tompa's let us know Thomas what the [ __ ]
well I just I'm taping that HBO thing
tomorrow okay that's a stand-up yeah son
of a [ __ ] Giada 12 screaming no you
know you yeah and and I'm on this tour
it's called the everywoman tour where
April Macie and Sean's hey Williams we
start in December well they start
tomorrow but I'm I'm taping tomorrow so
I joined them in this indie Center
cities so far we just started they just
started we got I think five cities
already no little bus
no three savages yeah that would be
don't don't
we're looking forward to getting to that
point you want to get to the point where
we get on the bus and you know I got
some TV stuff coming out at the
beginning and I'm working writing I'll
sit down and write a TV show with you
what is the when does the tour started
how many cities five you said yeah we
already got there still they just
started wrong yeah so we start we go to
Fort Lauderdale December 7th which I'm
excited about because I get to go home
to Miami so you guys are doing some
improv camp no we're doing Performing
Arts Center's okay yeah how many seats
um they're four or five hundred yeah you
guys know Shante she's the girl that
hangs on a flat Brazil up yeah yeah it's
cool this works yeah in the life up yes
he's one of the Wayne sisters yeah I
love her man she has a girlfriend
yeah yes I met her before she usually
hosts and I go down there and she's very
sweet and he told me his story one night
that she was all [ __ ] up yeah her
brothers held turned her cousins and
they took around the road with it
and if you see her on stage there's
something there yeah yeah she's gonna
need a couple tours but you're gonna
hear about that girl in about five years
you know no the [ __ ] she is seriously
yeah she's really honest and then April
April's been doing April as a [ __ ]
veteran of death yeah
April's Vince Howard Stern she's been
around since [ __ ] I was here
tormenting comedians you enjoy the looks
and yeah Laputa
yeah girl got my back she is solid she
goes another she also to stop giving the
[ __ ] yeah you know you said something
earlier that to be in this business as a
woman if my daughter my niece came to me
and they said listen though
I've been [ __ ] doing stand-up for four
years of the various I didn't want
either though you know I mean you know
whatever [ __ ] ma'am it's what you said
it's for a woman is you've got to be
crazy you have to be ready to attack
back the end of this business you have
to be fearless you know I told me this
story one time it was the weirdest their
meal they were talking about suntan I
told my story about a girl I met who
lived in Chicago nothing sexual happened
between and she was a waitress and we
used to always talk and she no I did a
few movies and one day she asked me she
goes what happened after you did a movie
did you become a star right away right
and I go first of all from the other
store I'm working here at your club in
South Chicago you know they're about to
throw bottles at me every [ __ ] star
no joke so what happened with this girl
was she sold real estate and she put a
little money away and haida
you know of people that you talk to pull
on the side you go can I talk to you in
the personal level I've been here for 15
years I've been dogging our bull nozzle
you know that and I've been with shitty
agents no management I'm looking at
breakdowns every day dropping off
envelopes you know calling casting
people tell them what a [ __ ] I am you
know what I'm what kind of life that is
yeah so when I've been doing it for 15
years do me a [ __ ] favor when you
come to me for advice don't [ __ ] around
that's come to me tell me the [ __ ]
truth and we'll get together and we'll
set your [ __ ] plan up and we'll set a
plan of attack me and my lion team no do
we have we're not sad here and set plan
of attacks and we don't execute like a
[ __ ] we do we get we don't flop
around me I want to come here on plan
and it's pretty crazy that's why it's
hard to remember it's really crazy how
you have to set things up and people do
not realize what was the release date
look at the release date of pretty woman
what's the move with him and Andy Garcia
March 23rd of 90 all right we'll hold on
keep that right there okay
what's the word with him Andy Garcia Oh
Richard Gere uh Richard Gere and Andy
Garcia was that not things are doing
Denver when you're dead what movie was
it um internal affairs
yeah what was the release date of
internal affairs okay in January 12th of
1990 what came up first that did by two
months what did uh internal affairs why
do you think that came out that way
have you watched internal affairs Lee no
yeah yeah why why we have orange is the
new purple all those of the dumb [ __ ]
you watch every night with the boss
internal affairs upon a dirtiest one of
the dirtiest cops ever and it makes
Harvey Weinstein louis c.k all of them
look like a [ __ ] sick [ __ ] I was a
year and a half lucky now he has one of
the Baldwin's words as partner and he
drives him crazy he tries to turn on him
he shoots him it's [ __ ] crazy Andy
Garcia's internal affairs he's hunted
and down at the end he shoots somebody
says don't have kids he had eight kids
right he had a chance this guy he was a
la cop that was dirty as [ __ ] but you
had a see how he talked to one lady was
like ain't doin a know what's going on
in your world no nothing just trying to
put the pieces together you look good
you know you're working out yeah
losing some balance but you busy right
there that really is just gonna help
pick up the kids call your mom tell her
go pick up the kids
let's go [ __ ] a little bit I mean he was
cold-blooded or forgiveness you left the
you know he didn't American Gigolo that
he did office in the gentleman he was
America's golden boy Jack when he thin
office in the gentleman with Debra
Winger god damn I got stuck on hot lady
first feet it was one of the Anthony I'd
to be a worker five on 57th and second
there was a double feature for two
dollars I like this more 25 I had a bag
of weaving of [ __ ] in Carvel and
learn like 2,000 chains I could take the
bus on the way home I could always sneak
up on a bus a bit so I had four hours to
kill I said I would not want to go see
officer and gentleman an American Gigolo
I was against my moral obligation but
the wind off the Hudson River convinced
me to go in there and sit there for four
hours in yell war and I watch that
officer the gentleman let me tell you
something blew my [ __ ] mind I'll work
with that director last year
Palin exhaling I'm like this dude is
[ __ ] real Jack read that to Richard
Gere to a different level in my world I
was like [ __ ] American Gigolo
show us as trying to steal my girlfriend
at the time at the movie theater why did
you ask when the movies came out because
he was a genius he came out as America's
worst [ __ ] cop you left that movie
theater hate but Richard yeah right but
it's two months
pretty woman him yeah and then only
people found one more they forgot all
about internal affairs
it was like a never [ __ ] of existence so
tell us the story you were telling us
about the waitress cuz you said she knew
waitress or you know I tell the [ __ ]
on the way down
Tommy store we talk about different
scenarios and I told me about a chick so
it was a waitress Chicago and Marino she
came up to me with a story that she
wanted to be an actress
hmm so she said she would ever shoot
movies in Chicago she took a job as an
extra but during the movie shoot the
director lighter and the actor like that
forget all the actor was a black guy
Oscar Wilde and he pulled her and he
made out with her during the movie they
do the whole thing legit and they added
this to the movie they wrote in a couple
lines and at the premiere in LA they
told they got an agent and lived here
swallow I'm at the comedy club and all
this is going down I knew about the
movie and there she is waitressing and I
go through graduation if I can't there's
my last weekend here I'm moving to LA
everything okay I like the way you move
until the publishers be my boyfriend
take you this place it's in dr. Fatah
it's now this is 15 [ __ ] years ago
mm-hmm this [ __ ] is like we got a place
off of Wilshire 427 50 M 100 K he's a
waiter I have some money put away I like
a why are you getting 2754 one-bedroom
because he knows he has to move to
Hollywood and she goes well no Hollywood
the dirty she goes when I move there and
we have a screening room and people come
over to the house that agent had twisted
her oh wow
this poor girl told me how I was [ __ ]
up my career why was a [ __ ] by this time
I had done some movies and I was talking
a good auditions my stand-up suck dick
like a dud no no
had nothing to do with that it was I was
more focused on the acting either there
was no opening for me understand that
and she's talked to bunch of [ __ ] and
that in searing it I'm totally about
this how I saw the decline off the bat
like I think I bumped into a once after
Holly of dishes going well I meant with
this kind for lunch and he's making a
decision listed [ __ ] 12 years later
me and legal Holly with the new family
at a bar we park we go in
I only you hungry we go now eat we went
the winter ball with the water noise
and finally waitress Oh following the
story I told him what that brought that
was a genius
there she is that's what she told me oh
great to see you oh my god oh my god
you're so t if he goes yeah me and my
boyfriend broke up when I met this new
guy he's the head bartender here I love
the assistant manager now I know yakked
thinks he does not really I just wrote
it so it's so weird this [ __ ] you get
tricked into believing she had a
publicist Wow
that's when they told you to have a by
totally I totally and I've told the
people is to this podcast that there's
scams in there's a 10% scam here that's
called publicity that it is like
throwing [ __ ] money away how much do
you think she was spending a month who
that woman the bartender like when she
first moved here but she's been away
10,000 them on 45,000 oppa Blissett
Oh what 3,000 over unless I listen to
slam what a good publicist it starts at
four to five grand
yeah that's who you just want to go to
premieres like like half those people I
went to Coco last night mmm-hmm I got
invited that cuz of my name not cuz a
stand-up not cuz the director like me I
could love to tell you that but it's not
they knew I had a child blah blah blah
blah blah blah but I guarantee if there
were people there that paid a publicist
yep like there was a bunch of kids
taking pictures okay now I'm gonna
[ __ ] genius
brightly those kids wasn't me okay now
what there's two three there's two or
three things were going on there a
either their potential Disney kids and
Disney is trying to promote them why put
them in a little high shots or be it
smiles with a dream now my wife pointed
something out to me and she's always my
second voice well I like the leg of your
right and she pointed a month that was
their fun son to be a celebrity when
wiped out look at when we sat down to
eat they were taking pictures of one of
that thing and when we got up to leave
they would take some pictures in front
of that thing let me tell you one of the
biggest scams various American cameras
ever listen you come anytime you need a
publicist there's publicist I don't get
you all those parties Lee you want a
little party's me uncle all those
mid-level parties and I guess what I got
a secret for you was that if there were
anybody they wouldn't be there anyway ya
know my first couple years here I used
to feel bad that I wasn't invited to
like the Grammys I have two big night
here for some reason like those award
shows getting invited to those we go
into the parties I've never been to one
yeah you see me sitting here we did on
the Grammys wishing I got it why don't
give all Frenchmen [ __ ] I don't care
anymore but all right that's number one
number two what am I gonna tell them
what we're doing on the show to hang out
at one of the parties to talk to who
eventually somebody's gonna what do you
do I'm a stand-up comic at the Comedy
Store really why the [ __ ] are you here
yeah it's that simple
yep unless you want to be embarrassed so
that's this sub publicist told Paley
you'll pay them and you go yeah wanna
promote my podcast and they'll take your
$3,000
guess what brother you go to parties
like without one last night which is
nothing wrong with I'm not saying
anything bad but in your mind but did
you smooth people did you go make
connection with people talk to me hi
Hawaii I come for the head of whatever
how cool [ __ ] like that but it's not
I didn't leave they're going home going
he's gonna put me in his next book right
now is it like I don't know a call like
let's say I hired a publicist like let's
say my goal was to go to the next Star
Wars opening and me [ __ ] the head of
Disney and give him my script
can I do that at whatever the other
thing or no oh my god if you about that
much your puke my lips have one of those
things you just have to think about who
you're giving this script to and the
situation I want you to think of what
you do I want you to tell you what
happens to me last week I meet my
friends over bar and one of them gives
me a box the size is [ __ ] thing just
take this hold for your baby i sat there
for 10 minutes I thought about the truth
the truth of the matter is I was gonna
take him back to the hotel maybe yeah
maybe sometimes I forget that [ __ ] I
don't look back maybe and then I was a
ship it I don't know I don't [ __ ]
know but in my heart I was not taking
that my luggage and eventually I called
the road when I told her the truth son
this to me really I hope that him bring
a winter jacket my luggage got
everything now then everybody [ __ ]
with the jacket you know but so we're
when people give you stuff
well people gave me great cards last
week and they're your cousin what the
[ __ ] happened to I always bring those
cards home well he's getting the
shoutouts um let me give some shoutouts
a real quick as I get Lauren I don't
like to know I think I'm getting old
top-quality Tony Leon my man Vegas over
there and [ __ ] Spain smacking people
playing on driver he said he hired a
driver Bob Ling there's always thinking
about you and your deck god bless them
one by one podcast I had an actual
little runny nose John Wolfe G Gino
jackal belly and the Hoboken Police
Department and Benjamin Paul don't
forget December 3rd me and we love
Walker LA at the Novo the fourth at the
observatory
San Diego and the fifth at the
observatory in Santa Ana you wanna plug
in 8 days beautiful yes December 7th we
are everywoman tours going to be in Fort
Lauderdale you can go to my website
funny AI da calm and get your tickets
there and we're also going to
Pennsylvania and Maryland on December
29th and 30th and February Valentine's
Day weekend I'm gonna be at the
Sacramento punchline so get your tickets
because I usually have good shows there
so get your tickets that's a great great
club I love it I think it's just perfect
yeah it's his purpose I like I like what
the club is I will switch hotels this
time I'm gonna go around the corner they
said and I like this out of town they
got real off-road I get to run with some
white people I got [ __ ] the habit is
across the street the malls right there
the malls right there but they have no
good food the sushi place that not that
side across your side is good on the
side of the hotel the sushi place is
very good yeah I will tell you that it's
open till 2:00 in the morning
a lot of people don't know that you
could do the show and go over and eat
sushi oh how do you know it was open so
soon though wanted to something like
that don't matter you can still get good
sushi no matter what [ __ ] that you
get out of stage opening a little frilly
road they give us coming yard you don't
say
I had some really good sushi every if
you guys ever been down to like that
japantown Sawtelle a street
no it's in like like in West LA it's
right off a 405 you wanna hook a good
time let's ask you that yeah we had a
great time
what was the hype what was the highlight
of the trip uh my cousin came over what
she cooked food she hook she cooked my
favorite meal with brisket and latkes
and green beans and then we went to the
observatory that was nice and then yeah
we had a great time so thank you you bud
ah I try not to think about it but then
you know and she's like it's always
tough at the airport no no with her
buddy like just yeah I feel bad like and
then sometimes like ha I could be like
it's uh for a second as like I could
move to Israel be the flying Jew from
Israel but I yeah my mom lives in Israel
she lives in now outside of Boston oh so
uh but ya know uh yeah it's always nice
having her here that there's nothing
like having a mom cook for you and just
talk with you it's uh it was always nice
I don't do it adds it's about a
once-a-year thing right now it's Nathan
me a couple times a year because yes I
would definitely be embossed in this
field
oh gee she'll come to the woman
exception welcome each of these fruits
um well I was born in Boston I wish it
were that MGH er Brigham Young Oh
but yeah I was I think I was at UH
again it doesn't matter in a barber or
something I'm a lot about Porter weekend
family still lives in Boston a lot of
Puerto Ricans at the end end over yeah
well my family's in Roxbury something
with an end over and then you grew up
Miami for a while yeah Miami in New York
and you really try to write this sick up
yes I started I did I gotta show you my
Bible I wrote a show Bible but I want it
to be real if I don't if I can't that's
the thing about me now you have always
been enforced that is if I can't be me
and I can't be real I don't want to do
it well here's the deal you gotta
whenever they propose you a deal
if it's a mediocre Network they're gonna
want to add something for that flavor
you're gonna have it mildly and whenever
they tell you they don't like about your
dream you're gonna do something
different to a sidebar to distract them
on the shows number one then you throw a
model room like world Zambo yes I see
telling me you're following me it's they
don't know the formula and we do we've
been doing it for 15 years longer than
we know the nail they went to a college
they worked himself as uh gloves
assistant I have a lot of respect for
that but I also know how to put a show
into segments and when this show should
have laughs and what it should it should
be serious you know his different parts
and you said that but that's what they
couldn't figure out how to translate it
onto television or film you know and
Rosen's a bad [ __ ] he was a pioneer
sword she always she told me that um she
would support me she's like in whatever
way I can help you I will
she's they're very real supportive of me
but she's the one roles that right now
yeah I do I do the same TV right now I
think it's a bit too late
I think you know everybody likes narcos
we want to see about drug money and what
happened to Noriega and Chapo's next
season and what happens in Mexico so you
know Netflix is winning not because they
take ninety-nine a month Netflix is
winning because of all the content
they're giving you a Freightliner every
month it's amazing from documentaries to
TV shows to stand-up specials you know
it's it's a great deal you cannot get
mad at them you know I don't love this
so packages your king or what do you
mean you know get NFL and they don't yet
but I would imagine they might start
they who knows they don't right now yeah
they've become a network the only thing
that scares me with them and I don't
even
they're doing great so this is a this is
just from an article that I read that
they're like four billion dollars in
debt or some includes a little Netflix
because of all the production they're
doing but I mean there's obviously
getting they have millions of
subscribers paying $10 a month whatever
it is so they're they're doing fine but
it's that does he seem that number was
crazy
yeah they don't seem worried no no they
don't
if you want to sell you his special
Netflix they lose talking Spanish a
little bit of Spanglish well they'll
sell it because they do great with the
Spanish market
I've watched three Spanish shows narcos
celeea and [ __ ] Jota Jota Pablo
Escobar's hitman 60 episodes between the
plane rides of the last three or four
weeks for one Lance of six our last
seven weeks I watched four episodes two
episodes there one episode back three
episodes there one episode back one of
the hotel room and they were very
interesting and like the chances they
took what the topics they took Netflix
is very good and even if they raise
their prices tonight and listen it's a
dollar water you spend a level a dollar
less you spend on [ __ ] yep for the
program and you get not to mention the
[ __ ] that they have all from time to
time from sons of anarchy the [ __ ]
earnest or that old arc is good about
the money laundry yeah they got some
good shows on I know that I like and
movies and documentaries they got the
best documentaries like they can get
caught up this should make scenery from
the planets [ __ ] flat when he got
plans for New Year's Thanksgiving my
brother I'm not sure yet we'll find out
making a turkey you go on a wife's house
and having the chicken ie honest I just
found out like yesterday that a
Thanksgiving next week so I'm not sure
you know what the plan is gonna make
your old target when you make your old
turkey last year yes I did
I think I might do that again we'll see
and what do you got planned for
Thanksgiving my cooking cooking at home
yeah you know those turkeys the they
call them the turkeys that are Cuban
style they taste like like a ham or
right that's what we do i season the
turkey like my grandmother taught me I
make our andouille
I make all the authentic food and I'll
make some American stuff but I always
cook for Thanksgiving and you're always
busy you always seem like you're right
and so yeah I think what are you
thankful for this year Thanksgiving I'm
thankful for my family I'm really
thankful for my family I'm thankful I
have a new niece and a new nephew and
they just just brought back brought our
family back to life cuz you know my
grandmother died a few years ago and
then my uncle got murdered in Miami so
I'm just thankful for those babies and
you know what I'm thankful that I get to
do what I love to do right even [ __ ]
up every day you ever get on a plane and
go how [ __ ] up is this I get to get on
a plane I just had a cheeseburger with a
bang on it with the American terminal
and I'm gonna playing at eleven o'clock
to go to Chicago it's out so I'm gonna
go meet my friend from college and meet
up for a drink or two and then tomorrow
night I got two shows and so on and so
forth yeah I feel the same and you know
what I am also thankful because there
are a lot of people who don't who don't
[ __ ] with me and but the ones that do
they [ __ ] with me heavy and I'm really
thankful for that because there have
been some people who have really made
things happen for me and I'm feel very
they understand me they don't want to
change me and I'm thankful for that
how about you really think what was it
I'm thankful for uh
everyone and myself was healthy I'm
thankful that this podcast I'm gonna go
therapy this year um thankful for my
friends and yes that's it what about you
what am i thankful for my wife my
daughter for the people who listen to
the podcast I'm thankful people come to
these shows and thankful to my cat's I'm
thankful for lead you don't think
for you guys before the podcast started
with all of my energies yep and people
that come in and out of your life
sometimes they they step away and you
know you know what life's been different
says that kiss of death has been around
they came around for six years my cat
died my brother went to jail my house
burned down you know sometimes you feel
guilty about people that I'm just
thankful that I get up every morning you
know what I'm really thankful I'm really
thankful when I'm driving down Laurel
King and I get carsick okay I get
carsick whenever I go down Laurel King
and right around when I get past the
little city restaurant there that little
place for the summer sandwiches I told
you I think about how lucky I am doing
54 years old I'm still doing spots at
the college though I swear to God I'm
like what they might get an anxiety
floor and what is this car sickness for
I'm 54 years old
I should be irrelevant not even at the
store at this age and I'm going down
there to do a 10 o'clock [ __ ] spot
and might cause sickness and everything
goes on what happened I'm thankful the
people isn't to the back yes I'm back
where you came up oh I'm happy you gave
the dates I want people to get to know
you they haven't heard a lot about you
you have good people too I was that I
told you I was that a restaurant the
other day and someone was like I know
you from the church and I'm like the
people who listened to this podcast are
real honest and loyal and that's what
people like me you look for in life oh
sorry about the star death get you to
the hospital you know what though
there's gonna be a great episode for the
TV show yes because it's 2014 18 Arabism
pretty soon it's true man ever since
I've gotten into me on these this is all
my way when I go to a gym wanna have
shorts on and [ __ ] they're comfortable
it's the mold all distraught this cotton
you'll ever wear and if you're sweaty if
your monkey sweats you put on a pair of
me undies it keeps the sweat under
control I told you people I had surgery
one time I couldn't take a shower I
sniff my nuts the next day they were
fresh well the most the time you just
get your nut after a day will not better
then quote your mother yeah I've done
that which means your balls know like
salt water and vinegar anyway every year
millions of people received the least
like gift of all time those white
underwear tighty whities but we still
give it to our family and our loved ones
who just don't want it but maybe it's
just the underwear is the prom it's the
kind of one the way that you give them
let me tell you about me undies the only
underwear that makes an amazing gift
like I said before mo dong swap this
Kanye level where there's throughout the
flexible waistband that three times
softer than cotton and most importantly
their national their natural sustainably
shorts fiber they're the most
comfortable things you'll ruin your life
there's one module Fiat for the holidays
all right it's a new year you haven't
gotten out you haven't got a little su
column Inc and even if you do you
everywhere and those tighty-whities will
be phases to put your pants on cuz
you're still living in 19 [ __ ] 82
this one but do for your right this
holiday season for yourself for your
little brother who needs a little
something just luck what you're gonna do
is you're gonna get I'm gonna give you
the exclusive 20% off the softest
underwear and socks you'll ever wear and
free shipping and on a percent
satisfaction guarantee
did you hear me right you're gonna join
I didn't [ __ ] hear you right what
i'ma do for you this holiday season son
tonight I'm gonna get you an exclusive
20% off the softest underwear and socks
you
everywhere free shipping and a for the
percent satisfaction guaranteed go to me
undies comm slash Joey again that's me
love these calm slash Joey's you're
gonna be happy ordered them why because
they're the best I wouldn't even talk to
your bottom if they weren't the goods
that's the type of guy in it's like
right now on it why do I like on it
because I live on it
they're family I'm partly on it family I
got a hashtag solid family you know why
because they taking care of you over the
years I got my little alpha brain cycles
I see how my writing improves when I get
focused not to mention the shrimp export
not to mentor the shrimp to commune not
to mention the help force protein what
I'm telling you is gonna calm look at
what they got to offer you there's got
something that's gonna work it's here
the Alpha brain start with that and
start with the heme Force protein they
could cow you will not be sorry go to
Anna calm look at the fine line of
supplements then go to a box on the way
out and press Church ban CH you are CH
[ __ ] and get 10% off delivered
the house that's on it number two for
the last two years I've worn the Fugees
I've gone from an a 625 the doctor
supari odd oh they got the the say cow
which means world and Japanese then they
are another more expensive one I'm
telling you to look at the super odd oh
they got a little blue with a nice green
trimming they got a little white and
they got a beautiful black which doesn't
get as dirty people can't notice as much
I went with the traditional white the
black and the blue that's a type of
jiu-jitsu guy I don't want my ghee to
sweat like whole [ __ ] sweat because I
could smell it on myself and then I'm
sorry I'm [ __ ] there not to mention
Fuji Sports calm has
rash guards they have a sale going on a
stuff of that starts do me a favor if
you're into martial arts or you need a
new Georgia to leave for the holidays go
to Fuji Sports calm right now and find
someone on the box pressed Church I'm
getting your 10% off and they're gonna
hole
yup alright I want to thank Fuji Sports
calm
I want to thank me undies calm and I
want to thank other calm but most
importantly I want to affect my Latin
flame miss Ida Rodriguez had took a
bullet last time and didn't cry she
didn't run away she called me and they
said like a woman that knows you and I
gotta believe what happened and that's
what it's all about you bad
[ __ ] only you have a great
weekend
we'll be back Monday morning tip-top
Magoo no [ __ ]
Lisa at the [ __ ] Joey Diaz I
love you and my main girl ina
Rodriguez Gonzales one of those slide
Regan Rodriguez I love your
[ __ ] have a great weekend blast
him Lee